IF YOU ANSWERED YES,
YOU'RE PROBABLY CARICATURE
ARTIST GREG DOHLEN.
HE WAS THE ONE THAT DREW IT.
AND AFTER TWO DECADES
OF DOING CARICATURES,
HE HAS YET
TO MAKE A NAME FOR HIMSELF.
- IT'S ALWAYS A STRUGGLE.
AND I'VE KIND OF--
I'VE BEEN DOING THIS
SINCE '89.
- BUT SOMETIMES
THE SOLUTION IS AS SIMPLE
AS KEEPING UP
WITH THE TRENDS.
- YOU DREW ME HERE.
- YEAH.
- IT'S ENJOYABLE
TO SEE YOURSELF
PORTRAYED AS A CARTOON.
- YEAH.
- BUT I DON'T THINK
IT MAKES ME LAUGH.
CARICATURES
ARE INSULT COMEDY.
- WELL, YEAH.
- IN THE CATEGORY
OF INSULT COMEDY,
JUST TO SHOW YOU WHAT'S
CURRENTLY POPULAR RIGHT NOW,
HERE, JUST WATCH.
- I LIKE YOU, JASON ALEXANDER.
I FIND YOU SEXY.
KISS ME, YOU FAT [bleep].
I'VE ALWAYS WANTED TO SEE
WHAT JERRY SEINFELD'S
[bleep] TASTES LIKE.
- I SHOWED HIM A CLIP
OF THE WILDLY POPULAR
COMEDY CENTRAL ROASTS,
WHICH PROVED THAT TO BE
A HIT IN INSULT COMEDY,
THE MEANER YOU ARE,
THE BETTER.
THE PLAN:
TO RE-BRAND GREG
AS "THE KING OF STING."
- UM, I'VE GOT--I'VE GOTTEN
MORE NEGATIVE REACTIONS
FROM GOING EXTREME
THAN POSITIVE REACTIONS.
- NO ONE LIKED ELVIS
WHEN HE FIRST CAME OUT,
YOU KNOW WHAT I MEAN?
PEOPLE WERE OFFENDED.
- RIGHT.
- BUT YOU HAVE
TO POWER THROUGH THAT
IF YOU WANNA BECOME BIG.
AT FIRST, GREG SEEMED
RESISTANT TO THE CONCEPT.
BUT AS WE STARTED
BRAINSTORMING IDEAS...
- YEAH, IT MIGHT BE FUNNY
IF HE'S CHINESE,
AND I MAKE HIM A PHOTOGRAPHER
WITH THE BIG BUCK TEETH.
- OH, YEAH, YEAH.
- LITTLE SQUINTY EYES
AND BIG BUCK TEETH.
- YEAH, YEAH, YEAH.
HE QUICKLY BEGAN
TO EMBRACE IT.
I LEFT HIM WITH A FEW EDGY
CONCEPTS OF MY OWN TO WORK ON,
AND HE STARTED
SKETCHING THEM OUT.
THE NEXT DAY, I RETURNED
TO SEE THE RESULTS.
ALL RIGHT, SO THIS IS
THE IDEA I HAD FOR A COUPLE,
AND YOU HAVE TO DRAW A COUPLE.
SO THAT'S YOU, THE ARTIST,
UH, DOING THE WOMAN
OF THE COUPLE FROM BEHIND,
DOGGY STYLE,
SHE'S SAYING, "I LIKE THIS."
HER BOYFRIEND IS LOOKING
AT A HUMMINGBIRD'S PENIS
AND THINKING, "THAT'S HUGE."
YEAH, THIS IS GOOD.
IT'S REALLY FUNNY.
THIS IS, UM, YOUR VERSION
OF AN ASIAN BUSINESSMAN.
UM, DO YOU THINK
THIS ONE, UH...HMM...
- SEE, I'M NOT--
I'M NOT SURE, UH,
WHEN YOU PRESENTED
AN ASIAN PICTURE
WHICH DIRECTION
I SHOULD GO WITH IT.
I WENT ALL DIRECTIONS REALLY.
WE COULD TRY IT OUT,
SEE HOW IT GOES.
- SURE, YEAH.
I MEAN, I'M NOT GONNA GET--
YOU KNOW, IN ART, YOU KNOW,
YOU DON'T WANT TO GET
IN PEOPLE'S WAY OR ANYTHING,
SO I'M NOT GONNA--
BUT, YEAH.
I MEAN,
THIS IS DEFINITELY--
I MEAN, THE PEARL HARBOR THING
IS ALMOST NOT EVEN A JOKE.
THE REST OF GREG'S NEW EDGY
CARICATURES LOOKED GREAT,
AND I COULD TELL THAT
HE WAS READY TO TRY THEM OUT
IN THE REAL WORLD.
- DO YOU HAVE ANY HOBBIES?
- I LIKE TO BIKE
AND SURF A LOT.
I LIKE SWIMMING, DEEJAYING,
PLAYING THE TROMBONE.
- THINGS WERE OFF
TO AN OKAY START,
BUT I GOT KIND OF WORRIED
WHEN AN ASIAN MAN SAT DOWN.
- I DRAW CARICATURES THAT ARE
A LITTLE MEAN AND EDGY.
ARE YOU OKAY WITH THAT?
- DEFINITELY.
- YEAH, OKAY, GOOD.
HOW'S THAT?
YOU LIKE IT?
- YEAH.
- OH, GOOD.
- BUT I WAS WRONG.
THE GUY LOVED IT.
YOU LIKE IT?
- YEAH, YEAH, I LIKE IT.
- AND FROM THEN ON,
IT WAS SMOOTH SAILING.
- OH, NICE, MAN.
- WILL THAT WORK?
- THAT'LL WORK, DUDE.
[both laugh]
- GREG WAS HITTING
NOTHING BUT HOME RUNS,
AND IT WAS AMAZING
TO WATCH HIM WORK.
- OH, NICE.
[laughter]
- SO HOW DO YOU FEEL
IT ALL WENT TODAY?
PEOPLE LAUGHED.
I SAW PEOPLE LAUGHING.
- PEOPLE LAUGHED.
LIKE, THE DEEP SIDE
OF PEOPLE'S HUMOR COMES OUT
WHEN YOU SHOW THEM SHOCK.
- YOU KNOW, AT THE BEGINNING
OF ALL THIS,
I HAD YOU DRAW ME,
IT WASN'T FUNNY.
SO NOW WITH EVERYTHING
THAT I'VE TAUGHT YOU,
I'M SAYING GO AS HARD
AS YOU WANT ON ME,
AS MEAN AS YOU WANT.
- YOU WANT THE KING OF STING?
- I WANT THE KING OF STING.
- OKAY.
- 'CAUSE I WANNA LAUGH.
- ALL RIGHT,
THIS IS FUNNY,
BUT IT'S HARD FOR ME
TO SEE MY GRANDPA
DEPICTED IN THAT WAY.
HE'S A CANADIAN WAR HERO,
AND HE'S, LIKE, A VERY--
HE HAS, LIKE, A VERY IMPORTANT
ROLE IN OUR FAMILY,
SO I DON'T LIKE SEEING HIM
DEPICTED LIKE THIS.
IT JUST--
IT WAS A REAL SHAME THAT
GREG CHOSE TO END THE DAY
ON SUCH A TASTELESS NOTE.
BUT REGARDLESS
OF MY FEELINGS,
HE TRULY WAS
THE KING OF STING.